I'll how to get the critical mind back
in our society a critical mind which
makes it possible now to cut through all
kind of knees and say well that's known
so so that's the past or how it may be
it may be that it's events like this
it's it's certain political exchanges to
contradict what I said earlier that it's
that that the critical mind can only now
be produced in institutions other than
those of traditional education because
although I spent most of my life in
universities and in traditional
educational institutions I have to say
that among the changes of the last 20
years which have been the most
regressive has been the remodeling of
educational institutions as industries
the remodeling of educational
institutions as market-oriented
institutions that's to say with internal
profit fantasies sort of profits that
they make reap the key one of the key
errors I think of the last 20 years it
was quite different from deregulating
markets is that all social institutions
have to be restructured as markets in
the and that means an incredible
hollowing out of ethos I was lucky
enough to go to a traditional
institution in which that had not yet
happened a traditional grammar school in
Britain followed by a traditional Oxford
College not from the background where I
could my family could afford that but
even if issues of access which have
gotten worse with the increasing
inequality of modern of recent times
were resolved what you would go to all
these institutions have been to some
extent deformed not to say that there
were no problems there were all kinds of
problems they weren't were they were a
pig or various difficulties of many many
kinds one didn't have any nostalgic few
of them but the key element which is
lost and the key is is the idea of
institutions with their only thoughts
and with having a non-market ethos and
that i think in education would include
as in a critical element the implication
of skeptical thinking the implication of
a disciplined sort of thinking in which
the fact that you want something our
hope for it is not by itself a reason
for thinking that it will and can happen
and that's a cat sister that that's a
hard a hard discipline which needs to be
taught but at the moment I'm afraid I'm
not too confident that within the
institutions where that we have which
are organized if not around status then
around market notions that they will or
can provided about the British press and
that respect sorry could you say
something about the British press how
what which aspect I mean there are so
many there are so many proliferating
evils as it were connected with it but
no one can say something good about the
British press you know in this respect
which is that we take an example not so
well known as the more recent scandals
there is a recent case of a office of a
servicemen who'd been damaged I thin in
Afghanistan I think Rory might know
about it who was went to prison for
having a gun which she hadn't this chart
which he hadn't handed in which he'd
forgotten about and I think that example
that case probably if that if the press
had not taken that up so along with all
the other things it does intruding in
people's lives and they've infused
criminal techniques of phone hacking and
all the rest of it if that case hadn't
been pursued by the press probably he
would have might have stayed in jail so
I do think you know I do i do think that
the with all its unruliness and its
anarchic tendencies and the actual
crimes and invasions of privacy that the
press has been involved when and
collusive relations with elements and
the police force and with enormous some
powerful press magnates I do think
actually that old-fashioned press
freedom is still important yeah I think
the problem is that we have lost a sense
of the real of the local of the
political I think we exist in a world of
extraordinary
abstraction I mean that's true for our
educational system it's true for our
universities it may sometimes even be
true of the discussion on this panel
right that we are a collection of people
with particular specializations who
aren't actually engaged in a
conversation you if Kenny keeps saying
when are you going to challenge my
theory on technology and everybody else
is talking about whatever else they want
to be talking about right understandable
um um which is why I think the solution
must slightly lie in getting off this
kind of panel into a particular real
situation I mean we pose a sort of moral
and political philosophers in an
extraordinary vacuum using a few little
anecdotes and the way in which my
students were taught at Harvard was very
very similar you know we created a
culture of academics who knew nothing
really attracting an idealistic young
students and giving them series of
development series of intervention
series of this theories of that and
every student goes away with our
takeaway and we have to sit and listen
respectfully if we were really down in a
particular place dealing with problems
that we had to justify with this
affordable housing scheme with
installing this broadband in this
village with working out the road
network a lot of these problems fall
apart the problem basically is that you
can't have a civilized educated elite
when that elites are no longer connects
in any way with the real the local all
the political would you like to
life conservation because it's very
local and on the ground it's very ground
up and it has to work with people who
live there because unless the people who
live in a place can be convinced that
there's something good for them in this
no conservation effort will work so
you're engaged on at the same time with
people who live in a locality his nature
is very localized and with conserving
habitat and conserving species I think
Greg's I invite you yeah it's a great
except for and the other reason I invite
you is this of the money given to
charities in North America for an
example ninety-seven percent goes to
people things things having to do with
people hearts kidneys arts whatever it
may be education whatever it's all about
people of the remaining three percent
half goes to pets cats dogs parrots and
gerbils that leaves one and a half
percent for all the rest of nature the
nature upon which we depend so get down
and dirty with the nature people like I
think what you're all invited okay can I
just want to reiterate what are already
has said actually we need to rediscover
and may be here and fashionable to say
in a forum like this but we need to
rediscover how to think small there is a
tyranny of big ideas out there everyone
wants to be a big thinker I mean look at
the success of the ted conference every
month to think big and preferably in 18
minutes as if you could deliver a
solution to every single problem of the
world in a very short space of time
using as abstract of a language as
possible it's a fetish everyone wants to
be in the business of big ideas no one
wants to go and get dirty and get
empirical and actually investigate how
many of the technologies for example we
talk about have completely different
logics that's why I am opposed to using
a term like pasta
logica because it assumes the technology
has a coherent logic do it there is no
coherent logic to it and you know what
ordinary people know that that's why
they find most of us so didi on the
other hand we chose our series do not
match their empirical experience with
their cars which they devices can
definitely not bad the other video on
the other hand we don't want people with
no ideological fix to crime I mean I
mean analyst would make it impossible in
other things we use technology to make
sure the thinnest and people don't go to
jail you can do this technology you have
a kind of code it can't kick may not
came to I admire very much said you know
there is a kind of danger in there's a
great danger in people running around
with great ideas great ideas in the 20th
century where with great casualties and
there's an eye it's very dangerous but
there's also a danger in saying let's
get back to practice because actually
practice very often consists of the bad
ideas of a previous generation Charlie
this exactly John don't tell me John
this is me this is exactly not what I'm
saying all right the point is to try to
put the ideas into practice the point of
the political sphere which you're
abandoning in many many ways through
this kind of conversation is exactly
discussing ideas and contesting ideas in
the local context but if you have easy
but do you have a defective if you one
of the things is we're discussing the
whole issue is if all human beings were
adults already adults they're not they
have to go through families and schools
and so although I'm very critical and
not been rather skeptical of university
education as if how exists in many
countries we certainly can't write off
schools if people emerge from schools
with no coherent worldview with no
ability to think about ideas big or
small it doesn't matter in a sense what
you try and do it the local ground level
it'll not have terribly good results so
I do agree with that we should look back
at education particularly maybe schools
and consider has a lot gone wrong or has
it not gone wrong is it actually better
than we think what are the changes that
have in fact taken place why is it the
case that people emerge with the
capacity for critical thinking or not
you